hi and welcome to the Google glove bat
from podcast I'm Franciscan boy a
developer advocate for the Google cloud
platform and I'm here with my colleague
mark hi I'm mark mandal I'm also
developer advocate for Google cloud
platform and it's another episode of our
podcast yeah very excited about it so uh
I guess that most of you have heard the
first episode so just a little bit of a
summary of what we talked about
basically we have a podcast and there's
three parts of it cool thing of the week
the main content and the question of the
week yep so before we start with the
cooking of the week what are we gonna be
talking about today in the main content
yeah the main content okay so the main
content we want to talk about compute as
a continuum cool which is kind of the
spectrum of what we can do on on cloud
platforms it's I think it's kind of
interesting and hopefully everyone will
too nice I really like that you're using
continuum and inspect from that great
very fancy it's very send it via yeah
everything is very scientific cool what
about the cool thing of the week I'm
pretty excited about the cool thing of
the week I got to do I got to have the
chance to collaborate weezer very very
well known fellow by the name of League
a Borg we go to put a blog post out on
the Google cloud platform got a blog
nice all about HC be too and what Google
cloud platform does to enable HTTP to
you can read the whole full article but
I think the really big takeaway which is
really cool is basically we kind of just
do it for you yeah so really if you want
H to be to put an HTTPS load balancer on
it uh and that's pretty much all you
need as long as it goes through https we
do hv two if you're an app engine
customer and you go through https you
get HTTP two so used to get a speed
boost which is awesome and without
really having to do much work cool and
for those of them know what HTTP two is
I mean it to be true you have a virgin
to a [ __ ] to get is better sure but the
house why why why is it better so that
is an excellent question so um I know
that one of the things is its way faster
cut its age able to basically the server
rather than
having to cash on the plan every single
time the server is able to predict what
you're gonna ask for I just send you
stuff so i can do pre-loading which is
pretty interesting yeah so we can send
stuff in advance it tends to use like a
single connection so you can do
streaming a lot better okay so we used
to do tricks before where they should be
one where you'd like get like sharded
across different domains and do all
those sort of fancy yeah you have to
worry about that sort of stuff as much
anymore to cool it does really neat
stuff it's well worth looking at the
spec it's not particularly long yeah if
ever you need stuff I also heard one of
the things that I like the least from
web development which is when you have
to put all the images inside of one
single image and they're like religious
fries yeah yeah which is so painful to
do yeah basically it's not need anything
yeah yeah it makes things a whole lot
easier yeah that's wrinkle and I really
like that the fact that you can
basically forget about HTTP to just know
that it's gonna be there for you to just
need to get a load balancer before and
that's it that's pretty cool it's
actually really cool in that we sort of
have experimentations in there for quick
support on some platforms too nice she's
also very cool she's a UDP streaming
type of protocol but some some browsers
support yeah quick is kind of magic yeah
it's magic I don't know it just makes
everything faster right there you know
how it's a special magic yeah cool uh so
yeah that's that's a cool thing of the
week little reminder to to you to our
listeners if you have something cool
that you want to share love to have it
yeah let us know at the end of the
Bobcats will repeat all the ways you can
you can contact us feel it um okay so
for the main content the computers a
continuum yeah so this is really
interesting so like actually you had a
really good metaphor for this I think
yeah really i really like it actually
really like i kind of want to stop
everything with metaphor you had okay so
basically well for the compute options
we have basically you can say you have
the infrastructure as a service or IAS
or whatever you pronounce it very bad at
pronouncing that you have also
platform-as-a-service paas or pause and
then there's something in the middle
we'll discuss about later yeah and
another thing how to make the difference
between both and well I'm European and
in Europe all
uh being just in general better yah we
also have manual cars we chose Australia
as well yeah we did drive on the wrong
side of the road in America they call
them stick shift oh yeah so we have
stick shifts then and and I was thinking
about the difference between pass and is
yes driving a manual car or a stick
shift yep and I love Mattie car but then
I realized that actually that's kind of
wrong it could be more like when you
have infrastructure service you're
driving a manual car yep when you have
pas it's basically you are in a
self-driving car yeah I actually really
really kind of like this because okay so
infrastructures of service is really
like it's your infrastructure it check
your spinning up vm like you get just
basic machine nothing on them it's
totally up to you how you want to draw
how you want to like do stuff yeah if
stuff goes down it's on you all that
sort of stuff so like being a manual car
if you want to change kids you have to
do it yeah you want to go faster or
slower you have to break you know it's
kind of you know if you've been given a
car and it's up to you to go forward and
at the same time you could totally mess
up your gear box if you do it wrong yes
and that's on you I know about that
before yes I may have done similar
things um but then like I really like
the idea is like platform as a service
where you say to the car like if you're
going to stop driving how you're like
hey I want to go to the shops take me to
the shops your car besides through the
route you want to take it decides how
was to get there how fast to drive you
know avoiding obstacles and so on
platform-as-a-service you don't have as
much control but it's like well now I
can just get to where I need to go and I
don't have to do a whole bunch of other
stuff such as like infrastructure tasks
or security as much and they have like
that so I actually really like that that
metaphor and actually following the
metaphor a little bit deeper you can
also have a thin that like when you need
to learn how to drive a self-driving car
well that's it like you just get into
self-driving cars that drive me to this
to the store they learn they have to
drive them a stick shift well that's a
little bit more time yeah it's kind of
similar right like when you're a
platform as a service everything you
need to know is what you want to do it
that's it yeah when you have
infrastructure as a service you're gonna
have to decide on what OS you want to
run what library
you're going to be using how do you
secure your network on your login how do
you monitor it my dad stays up yeah all
that sort of fun stuff so yeah I really
like that that meant yeah yeah I think
that works really well I really like it
um so uh so how how do we offer those
things in Google cloud platform so
infrastructure as a service we have
Google compute engine so we can fire a
virtual machines you have a variety of
operating systems so debian ubuntu we've
enough for windows if that's your flavor
of choice and a few others as well we
have a list online which showed you
which ones of us are supported and how
much so we do coral as pseudo stuff but
they are their basic machines we put
some stuff in them make them a little
bit more secure and ability to like ssh
into them really easily but that's it
they're machines you can get you like
any extra details i mighta missed and
not really I mean it's basically you
just get virtual machines and you do
whatever you want to them so you can ssh
the apt-get install yeah you can mess
around you can you can break your
machine down basically and then just
delete it and career anyone if you want
to probably most interesting um we can
do like up to 32 cause we can do access
to disks yeah and there's all the
networking parts load balancers as we
mentioned before and so on so there's
basically like if you walk into a data
center like a like an ideal data center
you can just say I want more and more
machine here and now I want to connect
them with this cable that's basically
what you do yeah yeah yeah and you can
usually provisioning tools and spool
chef of it all that sort of fun yeah
there's also the money rain that comes
directly from it so you can see how
often the machine has been used yeah
like there's a lot of things going on
but it's basically just basic components
of virtual machines that you manage yeah
we do make some things a bit easier I'm
monitoring service kind of hooks in
automatically with their machines so
again I shrink you know sincerely manage
but yeah so that I mean that's that's
infrastructure-as-a-service that's
that's compute engine you know you can
spin on pm's yep so all the way on the
other side platform as a service what do
we got there so Blackthorne service is
one of my favorite products I use it all
the time it's
Google App Engine whoo and what google
app engine does basically it's like this
idea of ceramic are you run your code
you just put it there and that's it like
you don't need to manage anything else
you don't know you don't know what how
many instances are running I did just
like enough instances to run the traffic
you're getting that's it so it's really
easy to get started but also it scales
very well we talked about it a little
bit less than three yeah because the
Google klappa from podcast is actually
hosted on on App Engine but it's it's so
simple to use like you have yeah huge
huge players like Rovio with anger birds
they use that it just works very well so
basically the good thing is that you're
giving up a little bit of flexibility
that you have with with infrastructure
service so you cannot run everything you
want you have like a series of allowed
runtime so you have a go of course you
have Java you have Python and PHP yes
and then that that's pretty much it like
there's so many mutations on how you can
access the network and things like that
[ __ ] it's kind of easy to adapt any
application to it but you still have to
adapt it it's worth noting though like
you can't run your own custom code on
there you can write you know you can't
write to the file system you have to go
through outs from a storage request
can't take longer than 60 seconds yeah
there's stuff like that and that's and
that's kind of the way it's built yeah i
mean the limitations for instance yet
wagon you can write to the class to the
to the file to the file system it's
actually a very good best practice right
because if you try to do that on a
single machine and that machine goes
down you just love the data sure so for
a web server is actually good practice
so basically we trying to enforce the
best practices for web development so
then once you're doing that we can make
sure that your code will scale to get
our traffic you get yeah it means it
means we can do things that make things
easier internally to be out of scale and
do stuff like that but much like your
self driving car you can't be like Oh
actually we need to go faster or take
this you know shortcut or something like
that yeah my very specific instance it's
like now the self-driving car is going
to get you there the way you want it
it's going to get you there yeah
in that's it and I think it's most of
the time it's basically what you want
yeah for me by default I will develop
stuff for our Benjen yep and if I get to
some point where I want to run something
like ffmpeg or imagemagick or things
like that yes one run on App Engine then
it will spawn at compute engine instance
on the infrastructure service side in
and you can have both and make them
communicate together so so yeah you can
get both the best of both worlds
tubercular yeah so speaking of best of
both worlds fantastic segment we were
talking a little bit before about how we
can have stuff that sources in between
infrastructure as a service and platform
as a service I think we have a couple of
offerings that they're available there
yeah so that that's a good thing that
the word continuum if I is indeed yeah
so we have both ends
infrastructure-as-a-service on one side
but for my service on the other yeah
what's in between so we have a couple of
things I mean we just talked about App
Engine and falling under that banner we
have something that's called managed VMs
now yeah that's cooked which i think is
actually really cool um managed VMs
pretty much lets you kind of sit in the
App Engine world where we manage things
for you but allows you to die to you to
the term but it actually makes sense
like break the glass ceiling you better
break through and say okay I actually
want to be able to either run my own
runtimes or um write my own code via the
way I want to write it in you know and
take longer than 60 seconds things like
that but I'm willing to give up a little
bit in terms of you know either the
management side so yeah pretty much
we've got some we've got Ruby support on
there I definitely member don't say yes
yeah a few other ones I can't think of
throw my head right now and you can also
provide your own doc files as well so
you can bring your own custom runtimes
if you want and yeah I let's do that and
that the good thing about it is that
we've also been working on the fact that
now you can be employed to manage VMs
without having to install doctor on your
own machines so basically just give the
code and we'll build it and apply it so
if the developer experiences it's quite
similar to App Engine is pretty good it
just write your
good incentive yeah and it's meant to be
very close so you can also still write
like job and Java and Python and PHP and
go much like you were before yeah I have
an existing app engine app and you're
like you know what for this particular
bit of my code I actually need to break
out maybe i need ffmpeg like your mentor
things like that i can still have the
infrastructure that i'm used to with lee
that engine but I can kind of go a
little bit further and be like oh I have
a container so I can put whatever I like
in it and that's that's really powerful
stuff every pocket so yeah basically
that's just going a little bit in the
direction infrastructure service but
definitely next to platform a sister yes
it's very platform-as-a-service a hey
yeah yeah uh do we have something in the
middle the answer is of course yes we do
we have something I think a little bit
further more towards the infrastructure
service side but still in that that sort
of platform as a service yeah that's a
crew burn at ease which I love the name
so I have a tendency to say communities
I think it's just because I'm Australian
I don't know why I mean it's a great
board anyway so I think that neither i'm
waiting for not know somebody should
definitely send us a phonetic sounding
someone was a great background oh yeah
that'd be nice yeah play it I think we
should buy it so yeah we had to accrue
Benitez's an open source project that
was first started by Google we can talk
about this for an entire episode oh yeah
I think we'll get some people on I've
got some interviews if that could be a
nice episode oh yeah but what we have is
is a hosted version called Google
container engine which is essentially a
poster cribben eighties communities is
really really cool the way I like to
explain it really quickly is basically
so it's really a container orchestration
service yeah and the way I like to think
of it is is containers are great right
we can go on with them for a while but
what do you do when you're like I need
five of these type and ten of these type
and I need six of these type I need to
make sure that this one can talk to that
one this one talks that one and these
two always kick started up together and
that's or stuff that's what Cooper
nudies does so it's a scheduling service
to make sure that hey I've got five
running of this I've got six runny of
that I've got ten running of these and
if a machine blows up or pod guy or a
docker container goes down then it
starts it back up again it says oh wait
that's going down sweet and what's cool
about it which I quite like is sort of
ubiquity of
containers doesn't really matter what's
running inside them the crib entities
can just do it in a very standard way
for all sorts of different types of
software application so I kind of like
it yeah just to give a more concrete
example something that I think for
instances you have like the typical the
hello world of the ship root systems
which is basically the guest book it was
a database they arms around I really
like that example because basically what
you're saying is like well you have you
have the the web servers and then you
also have the database right when you
have those web servers maybe you want to
scale like the web server container you
want to scale it over and users like oh
yeah I had one container and doing that
now i want to have 10 of those and maybe
you have five hosts five actual machines
running that right yeah and you don't
want those 10 containers running all of
them in one single machine so you want
to say oh yeah just your similar cross
and that's what contain what could be
ladies will do if one of those five
machines goes down those two containers
will just move somewhere else yeah so
basically it's the idea of you describe
what you want to have running that's
what we call the declarative approach
where you don't say what to do when
something goes wrong you just say this
is what I want do everything you need to
make that yeah so you still have you
still have the ability to kind of drive
the car but there's some self-driving
ask me yeah so it's it's more like it is
really in that middle isn't it yeah I
gotta like to think about it like you
basically self-driving car were you
basically saying you know what I
actually want to go through these traits
and you I need to avoid that pardon so
it's more like very very detail stop
driving that's not like a lane assist or
ya self parking or something like that
yeah I suggested going to that metaphor
yeah at some point that manifold will
break i'm sure yeah so yeah that's so
that's koo burn at ease and coo Burnett
is basically what it does is it's just
that orchestrate containers across the
fleet of machines those machines can be
running on Google a platform on
on Google container engine yeah they
could also be running somewhere else
have you been running on your own
premises they can be running anywhere
else what Google container engine is
it's just kuru Nettie's the whole thing
is managed by one master so what we're
doing with Garnett is is giving you an
easy way to spawn those instances that
you need to run the containers and then
1x for instance which is what the Goku
or nine is master that is managed by us
so we make sure that that machine will
never go down yes so that's the
important one yeah it's pretty easy I
mean it's pretty awesome you can kind of
go to the developer console yeah click a
button how many nodes you want I'd like
five please you click OK and it spins it
all up and creates a for you which is
pretty yeah it's a very very experienced
I really like it I really really like it
too that's a good thing I mean we should
we should definitely do an episode
coronaries yes there's really cool
things there's so many cool things okay
so sort of the recap I guess so on one
side of the spectrum we have like
platform-as-a-service so we've got app
engine and then as we continue a little
bit further towards
infrastructure-as-a-service we have
managed VM yeah we continue a little bit
further towards
infrastructure-as-a-service so we've got
a container engine Thank good 183 days
yep and then we go all the way on the
other side infrastructures of service
we've got compute engine yeah so that's
the continuum really that's it yeah that
seems pretty cool so really like
whatever you want to build we should
have a solution for you and hopefully we
can help you along the way as well with
something that tools yeah i think that
basically anything and the good thing is
that there's some solutions that will
work very well for infrastructure
service and some other thing is platform
service some other thing is more like
uber Nettie's or but the good thing is
that you can use all of them at the same
time exactly there's nothing that forces
you to go with one you can just pick at
you can choose yeah lovely all right I
think that sounds really great cool so
for the last part of the pop cast we
have our sin of the week yeah we have a
question of the week um so this seemed
to be around like someone's trying to
SSH into their machine from their laptop
from like a terminal command no um and
they're like this is an interesting one
so they know their details are correct
so I'm sitting at my machine and I
my password and my my credentials are
all set up correctly but every time I SS
a chain it keeps dropping my connection
and I'm really confused about what's
going on yeah so that happened to me
once yeah it was it was quite painful
because I mean if you know linux enough
yeah probably you know exactly what's
the answer i'm not a linux expert so it
got me confused a little bit so I like
to think I'm a linux expert i use been
using linux for a long time but i
actually didn't know the answer this at
all so i thought this is actually really
interests you so basically yeah like if
you tried every single time you try to
ssh or actually to connect in any way to
compute engine instance yep there's
gonna be a lot going on somewhere we're
gonna manage like just in case we want
to measure if someone is trying to
attack you these kind of things it
security stuff good stuff yeah so if
you're running ubuntu yeah by default
you have this little program called ssh
guard i'm not sure that i'm pronouncing
correctly message card I think I sends
forth between the two of us agh God that
and what Sh guard that is every single
time there's a connection event yeah so
as someone is sticking into it will
measure the dangerousness of the
connection so like how risky it is
however is getting a little bit strange
and the things that when you connect
them from front your laptop yeah turns
out that very often there's some dns
settings going on and basically your
laptop appears as something's lightly
risky or that instance okay doesn't mean
it's completely risky but you know it
doesn't even trust okay so it gives the
dangerousness of 10 which is a
completely random number to choose but
the thing is that once you get over 40
yeah then you get been so that's why you
may be able to connect once twice three
times and the fourth time you can
actually dropped and the only error
message you get is your connection hi
strap and so is that like you
reconnecting a lot over short period
basically yeah after a while so after a
while it goes down okay yeah so so
what's the solution for that well the
first thing you need to do is you need
to make sure that that's actually the
problem yeah maybe maybe your network is
not broken you're not able to connect to
that that could be so how do you connect
when you can
SSH into a machine well what is going on
is that your IP has been been right but
you can still connect using the console
okay frantic also you have the assisted
button yeah that would work every single
time okay said it so Google her platform
nose for compute and ssh if it's doing
it through the browser it's like oh
that's special yeah you know that's
great we know who you are where you're
using a private key than delegation so
it's different so you probably logged in
with two factor auth because we're all
using two factor auth when we use our
google accounts we all should yes and so
yeah we trust that connection a lot yeah
so that's that's a thing that that will
always work then when once you connect
in there you can do iptables dash
capital l there's a pseudo iptables
don't know who you are and that will
list all the rules probably here gonna
find one of those who'll sayings that
your AP has been been you can just drop
it to just iptables dash help or
something you'll see how to drop it it's
quite simple and once you've dropped it
that's it no you know now you're
elevating it can you white with stress
off and be like okay yes am I always
okay you can wipe this yourself
depending on the instances and the rules
that you have on your connection may be
harder or easier one of the things that
you can do is just say this is my IP
dumb ever block this AP yeah then good
you good okay that sounds great all
right cool good to know if I've ever
looked at about one of my own machines
now I know what the problem could yeah
it's good to know yeah great all right
correct so um finishing off why don't we
just recap with what events we have
coming up if people want to come and
talk to us so I'm about Google cloud
platform where we'll be so friends ask
where are you going to be headed in the
next little while so I'm gonna be so
there's DCP next thing parties that it's
happening like very very soon yeah I'll
be there then in November I will be in
or dev in mammo then i will go to Paris
for dot go it's a go conference then i
will go to what's the name def ox in
Antwerp in Belgium we're gonna have a
huge huge team there I think we're gonna
be like five or six of Google's like a
finger
and that's amazing yeah that's going to
be lots of lots of fun and then after
that the week after that I'm going to
Barcelona not for holidays this time
even though I have some but because
there's dark on Europe very good yep
okay great so i will be in november i
will be a future stack at in your relic
conference I just very excited about
that because Steve Wozniak will be
keynoting oh wow I was a sneaker page
receive Wozniak that made me pretty
happy as I mentioned in the last episode
I will be a closure college in November
as well nice talking about some
container stuff than development
environments which should be lots and
lots of fun sounds cool so yeah if you
are anywhere around there and you get
the chance come say hi yeah just make to
everyone yes and sends us a message on
on twitter or through an email so just
in case let's remember that so i will
wait upon website is gcp podcast com
yeah Twitter it's at gcp podcast yep
Google+ is google.com / + gcp podcast
what else and forgetting something
reddest it's our / JCP podcast and our
email is hello Jesus podcast I think
that's it yeah I think that's it seems
like everything ah well it's great to
chat with you once again princess yeah
and talk to you next week see you next
week bye